[Musique]
c'est surtout ce cas trop souvent des
bouts de pistes à bonfol
je venais d'intégrer le groupe de touche
pas à mon poste qu'est ce que ce groupe
c'est un groupe dans lequel on pense
qu'on peut rire de la télévision et oui
on en a marre des émissions médias
sérieuse n'est ce pas le public
et si on veut rire si la démo thierry
lorho télé7jours plaisir vous êtes le
plus chic de l'émission euros oui je me
suis dit qu'ils en mettant une cravate
je me démarque créé un petit peu tout le
monde vous vous démarquez je vous le
confirme
merci thierry avec mais également jean
michel maire on peut bien expliquer on
attend maintenant qu'il est fier d'avoir
ça va bien je me say about ten
fonctionne merci jean michel et enfin
christophe carrière de l'express est
également choisi officiel capillaire de
jean michel jarre
merci d'être avec nous denis brogniart
est avec nous ce soir
merci le travail devenu tel accueil
bonjour à tous bonera vite et ne touche
pas à mon poste gardent un honneur pour
nous aussi on plus on a pris quelqu'un
qui faisait beaucoup d'audience a
cartonné la semaine dernière koh lanta
heureusement que tu vas pas commencer la
semaine dernière arrivera pas pu
l'inviter à bari le choc des héros je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez vous dire
en colère il n'a pas voulu que je lui
étais n'y sa flamme oui c'est vrai il
m'a pris le brun comme ça
la manne moundir face à mon petit bras
flux et je fais autant vous dire que je
les ai sentis possède encore la barque
et à ce moment là la seule chose que
j'ai trouvée parce qu'il me dit non non
non non je veux bien que tu étais
flammes mais on va dans la forêt
imaginez c'est comme ce plateau là il ya
quand même huit ou neuf caméras on peut
pas partir dans la forêt comme ça en
freestyle
j'étais auxiliaire fallu faire c'est
trouver une idée pour qu'ils puissent
accepter que j'étais une sa flamme je me
suis dit tiens là tu es dos aux
aventuriers qui t'ont éliminé si je te
mettais de fass est finie vous allez
être face à ceux qui vous ont éliminé et
l'allemagne est d'accord doni ce que
tout le monde sait ou presque qui a
rencontré son ca son épouse sa charmante
épouse
si j'en commenta comment quand vous avez
fait vous pour la pour la charmée sur le
jeu parce que vous aviez d'autres choses
ont-elles j'imagine que vous avez dû
mener à la fois le jeu et en même temps
le jeu de la séduction non justement
comme chez pas faire deux choses à la
fois j'ai opéré cette séduction avant le
début du jeu j'avais toujours cinq six
jours avant le début du tournage et
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai réussi à
séduire
est-ce que vous avez séduit votre
fiancée comme comme dans koh lanta c'est
à dire vous avez les mêmes codes
c'est à dire quand vous lui parlez chéri
la sentence est irrévocable
north kit vous chéri prends ton sac va
récupérer ton flambeau et vient me
rejoindre pour les amoureux l'émission
qui n'ont pas suivi après ils ont gagné
un voyage mais malheureusement le coût
de ces brisé avant qu'il parte avant de
mettre les pieds et les mots si je suis
line donc moi je pense mais vous êtes
surtout sur moundir hall connais jean
michel merle merci jean michel mr
applaudissements pour lui
denis qu'est-ce que vous êtes grands
vous sur pleine croissance mais
qu'est-ce que je suis petit mois c'est
surtout ça mais en plus ça ouais non
j'ai une sarkozettes non mais il a une
espèce de petite porte mais la volée
venez venez venez pas venir montrer aux
téléspectateurs regardent et une petite
règle est là c'est normal
là c'est la position hanouna merci
et c'est mon président notre président
qui m'est offerte si cette petite
planète
merci denis